well I'm internet lore about you is that
you got kicked out of high school no for
making a porno is that true not exactly
you weren't in high school but she was
story on the record you know come on I
made a little magazine show and I
interviewed some people and when we were
shooting it there was some kind of racy
stuff some nudity it wasn't but there
was but there was nudity and are you
doing it like like with the high
school's equipment and all that super
pissed
they were pissed yeah yeah and I you
know someone went into my editing room
uh you know and whatever 16 years old 17
years old and you know they went into
the editing room I wasn't going to
present this stuff but I wanted to be
free and shooting so we had a good time
and someone saw the rough footage and
that's a lesson for you they ran to your
editing so this must have been the time
the living theater it was all around
yeah it's about that time but I'm also
very far from the living theater because
I'm a high school kid very
unsophisticated even happens in
Wisconsin just trying to make his way
how do you at sixteen how do you
convince girls to take their tops off in
movies Oh what you kiddin me but he's
really ugly George no I know do you sure
who's a guy when um when there was
public access TV I'm a guy that went all
over in like a silver LeMay a spacesuit
with home video equipment and he'd pick
up women downtown that were on their
lunch break and get them to an office
somewhere and get them to take off their
clothes by and it was interesting
because um people did it and just
because of the camera just because of
the camera and it was new at that time
you know video stuff was new and there
was I think there was also Quran about
you know just the strangeness of it no
so what what inspired you to do like
how did you know cuz like when I was 16
15 I'd be too afraid I mean George they
just put it up yeah the ugly joke yeah
but it was kind of amazing um that show
right I was amazed how he how he could
seduce people in today paying off their
clothes and you're like I could do that
it's as much about how people secretly
like to perform and like to you know
have something rather the usual happened
now are you sure he didn't meet them
before and work this out because I see a
lot of porno where it's like they're
meeting girls on the street but oh yeah
there that's before before the release
is really all right
yeah you just see a lot good yeah yeah
so you respond so how easy is it to tell
someone take off the clothes ask ugly
George yeah it's not that tough
but what were you and like inspired by
him or like wait I could don't know I'm
a kid that you know sees 60 minutes when
it's just for a starting and I'm playing
with video equipment and I'm gonna do
three interviews of these people but
right but take your top off - yeah
that's great that's great